hands up
[Music]
right
enjoy your hand out to me your hands up
come out here
one more hands up in here
walk out for me nice and slow
down right here
come on
come on step outside Josh
let's talk about what's going on
[Applause]
Lou come outside with us we'll figure
everything out
look
come on out to me
can you come outside come talk to us
what's going on today
Slow Hands Up In The Air
come out nice and slow
all right
turn around for me
don't work with us
you turn around for me
you turn around face away from me
you turn around
turn around and face away
turn around and face away from us
what's going on today
you all right you Medical
we have an ambulance on standby to check
you out but you got to come with us
turn around and walk backwards
can you kneel down where you're at
and yield down where you're at
kneel down forward
[Applause]
look we're only going to ask nicely so
many times
okay get down here in Houston
let's talk about this and figure things
out you gotta work with us though all
right
let me get you guys taken care of all
right just turn around
and go down onto your knees
okay turn around get down onto your
knees
foreign
[Applause]
you want to walk out here and talk some
more
okay come on more
clothes
or go down onto your knees one way or
the other either works
do you have any weapons on you or
anything
can you talk to me
are you hurt at all
the medical attention
huh kneel down for everybody
inhale down so we can talk
we can help you
yeah
good turn around
we need to get here to help you out can
you kneel down for me
can you go down under your knees
kneel down
don't get that shit all right we're here
to help you
keep your hands up and go down onto your
knees
don't stretch come on
look Last Chance down on your knees now
go down onto your knees
yeah